foreign
around the corner this National bats appreciation
week and yes there is such a thing in a small
Texas town they've taken appreciation to a whole
new level coming to the rescue of more than a
million mammals who've made the community their
home cbs's Janet shamlian is there it doesn't
look like a point of interest but this crumbling
Warehouse with shattered windows and sprouting
trees becomes one as the sun sets in Huntsville
Texas it's still way underrated as far as tourist
destinations thing things to check out Tommy Hoke
still remembers his first time I was blown away I
didn't know what to expect and then when I saw it
I just I couldn't believe watching it was amazing
it's a common reaction to the evening show
by more than a million Mexican retailed bats
emerging on mass for nighttime nourishment
from a place they've called home for years but
technically isn't theirs the bats are a population
the Texas State Penitentiary has long wanted gone
it owns the building effectively the bat's
landlord and has tried to get them to move
into these bat houses just 50 feet away there
have been no takers they're in direct sunlight
for nearly all day and they're painted black so
they're essentially what some people call bat
ovens earlier this year word came the building
would be torn down for safety reasons the fate
of the bats uncertain I was looking at
that building knowing what was imminent
it really just convicted to me that if I don't do
something now if I don't say something at least
make some sort of an effort it's something that
in hindsight I will regret for the rest of my life
hoax started to save the Huntsville bats Facebook
page thousands joined or made their own pleas
ant agreed to hit pause are you a bad guy I
wasn't but I am now you are yeah city council
member Russell Humphrey is part of a group local
leaders prison reps and bad experts working to
find the colony a home they will move to the
Texas Department of Criminal Justice tells CBS
news we are taking additional time to ensure
community members and Advocates are engaged in
the discussion when you heard that the prison was
going to stop demolishing the warehouse what did
you think I thought wow this is amazing I can't
believe because I had so many people tell me
it's not going to happen we like what
you're doing we we think that's great
yeah we wish we could save it but it's not going
to happen for now the nightly flights continue
the giant roadside statue of Texas General
Sam Houston is still huntsville's most notable
landmark but the bats are gaining ground in
its gift store there's recognition of the
city's unofficial tourist attraction you can buy
that t-shirt that cookie cutter even take home a
stuffed bath I have been out here probably since
may I uh probably 150 times with earlier sunsets
they're harder to see this time of year especially
if you're as blind as a well you know it never
gets old and a lot of times it's so rewarding
I'll hear little kids voices and the excitement
in there in their voice kids here tonight yeah
yeah and it's great I love hearing that children
like Adelaide who got this for you um I picked it
up myself at five already a bat fan I love bats
and I think they love me too the prison baths
for now granted a temporary stay for CBS Saturday
morning Janet shamley Huntsville Texas I could
be a bad girl I really could sure sure why not
you got a good outfit for it yeah yeah it
looks good I like this I like the stuffed
bat the stuff that was very nice yeah yeah
now is what you were saying about how much
bats eat every day mosquitoes they eat their
body weight in mosquitoes every day they don't
weigh a lot so they can help the environment
that definitely Dana's had some great back
trivia this morning yeah thank you Cindy Cindy
had great questions she looked it up for me